every
month or so there is some new headline
that they want to change james bond
james bond is a british dude and they're
always trying to change that and so
they're going to make him some other
ethnicity
which i guess is it's certainly more
plausible than the other option which is
they want to make him another sex
so james bond is going to become jane
bond or something like that
and it always pops up on twitter and
then it kind of disappears or it comes
up in the news and then it doesn't
really happen
but the producer of james bond barbara
brockley has now finally opened the door
to one of these possibilities she says
no james bond is not going to be a woman
but he might not always be a man
now i'm i'm no biologist
but i don't
i don't understand what so here's what
she says i think we should be making
more films about women this is an answer
will james bond ever be a woman i think
we should be making more films about
women i think bond will be a man
non-binary perhaps one day maybe
who knows i mean i think it's open we
just have to find the right actor now i
can't tell here
if barbara broccoli is being facetious
if she is peppered by this insane
suggestion so often that james bond
should be a woman that she says no no
not a woman he's probably a man
non-binary is that a joke is that taking
it into an even more extreme
area or is it not is she saying as i
think many people in the culture are
saying that no he can't be a woman
because that would that would be so
ludicrous but what if men and women
stop being like men and like women and
what if we
what if we pretend that there's really
not much of a difference between men and
women and what if we pretend even more
absurdly that someone can be neither a
man or a woman but something some
combination or neither or both
what about that
when guests come up to my door this
holiday season this is how i'm going to
greet them i'm going to greet them
holding up these two gigantic knives to
show off the incredible japanese steel
that they are made with kamikoto makes
great japanese steel kitchen knives
using more than 800 years of traditional
techniques from japan each knife comes
in a beautiful wooden heavy duty box it
makes sure that the knives are stored
safely and it makes kamikodo a great
gift each kamikoto knife goes through a
rigorous 19-step process that takes
several years from start to finish to
complete the expert blade smiths forage
and shape raw steel into hardy blades
polishing and sharpening them
to an excruciatingly fine edge each
knife is individually inspected kamikoto
is so confident about their knives that
each knife comes with a lifetime
guarantee i really strongly recommend it
kamikoto is currently having a massive
christmas sale and on top of that sale
you can get an additional fifty dollars
off any purchase you make with discount
code knowles canada wles so click the
link below
or go to kamikodo.com
knowles and use promo code knowles
canada l-e-s to save an extra 50 bucks
today
james bond will not be
non-binary
he won't be non-binary because nine
non-binary does not exist
i'm not saying that there aren't people
who mistakenly believe that they are any
of these crazy categories
but the category itself does not exist
it is not real
it like the hate crime against jessie
smallette is a figment of fevered
imaginations so james bond will never be
that
furthermore james bond will never be one
of these kooky gender things because
if the character known as james bond is
one of those kooky gender things he will
cease to be james bond because james
bond is
a dude with a funny accent who has a
license to kill and drinks martinis
shaken not stirred that is who the
character is
you can't go into the movie
and replace james bond with luke
skywalker and say that luke skywalker is
now james but they're just different
characters they have characteristics
it's not
possible even this line here this first
one is very politically correct look i
think we should we should be making more
films about women
but i don't think that we should take
the male movies and the male characters
and just pretend that they're women and
have the women pretend to be men
why do we need to make more films about
women
why is that something we really need to
do
is anyone asking for that seriously i
know that people are saying that to
sound politically correct and very
socially acceptable but does anyone
really want that i don't think so
because whenever those movies come out
with some exceptions they bomb at the
box office
certainly when
you take a property that i guess is not
necessarily gendered
you know like
ocean's eleven i mean i think i guess
really i think ultimately that is
a man's movie or a ghostbusters or
something and they make it with women
and the movies are terrible
or you make some
you know captain captain marvel right
that was the one with the woman i've
only seen a handful of these marvel
movies but the movie was horrible
and so you might say well even the
superheroes are generally men okay well
so
this distinction is a little bit blurry
but all i know is this whenever you make
a movie specifically to make more women
movies
the movies bomb and they're terrible
there are plenty of wonderful women
characters throughout all of literature
and film and theater
but they're not the characters that you
just
chew horn into there and really try to
make a point i don't i think we probably
have
during the golden age of cinema we
probably had the exact right number of
women movies or women
characters or whatever i think we had
the ex i think when movies were good
that was the right amount and now that
movies are terrible we have some wrong
amount and you're not going to correct
that by being even more politically
correct
but
the the destruction of western art is is
way worse than just trying to make james
bond have purple hair and a nose ring
you know and
wear androgenous clothing it's a lot
worse than that i'm glad you like that
clip
i am that makes me feel good especially
this time of year christmas time
i'm happy i feel i love our whole
extended family here
if you want to get all the notifications
you got to ring that bell subscribe go
to apple podcast spotify stitch or
google play wherever you get your audio
podcasts type in the michael noll show
subscribe for free leave a five star
review
see you next time
[Music]
you